I'm here with usually in Simon who plays
the land sell a Lannister in Game of
Thrones he's gone from Squire to a
knight you think he's a man with
ambition I think he is a man with
ambition I think if you're a member of
that family it's impossible not to
ambition really it's sort of a question
of Lance of having ambition and having
kind of enough spine to carry it out
really but yeah season two I think he's
trying he's definitely trying you think
he's trying in many ways as if he's
succeeding is a very different matter
he's not been very well treated in
either position though has he has a
squire and I because he's got you know
Robert Baratheon sending off for like
breastplate stretchers he's got firstly
in Tyrion using him basically he does he
does I mean I mean the using him is a
rather rather fortunate for him but the
thing is is that I think yeah he is
always he is always kind of on the on
the back foot really but I think a lot
of the characters in Thrones a lot of
the reasons that you kind of get so
invested in them is because there's
always that kind of attempt to try to
get on the front foot to always try to
be up with your superiors and those are
the characters that I persisted have
connected with it more closely that's
why lots or was someone I really liked
when I started reading the book so I'm
hoping that when season four or five in
accordance with the book comes out that
being able to be something that can
carry across would you like to see your
character growing cuz you haven't
actually seen him on Episode four if
they fight coming it very shortly of
season 3 why would you like to see your
character going well I mean I've read
the books obviously I know kind of
storyline wise where I would like them
to go I mean it's sort of the one thing
that I am really looking forward to
doing with the story that I know exists
is I based the whole of my performance
for the first two seasons on what I'd
read from the from the previous books
and the massive trauma that he undergoes
when he was seen season two or not is is
something that I thought was sort of
apparent tantamount to where he goes to
season 3 which is just a huge change in
personality his ideas what he
prioritizes and his relationship with
his family so I just really want to kind
of see I still want to see a boy turn to
a man for season 3 Lancel is on kind of
hiatus if you like he's
he's sort of m.i.a if you like from his
his endeavors at the siege of Blackwater
Bay and I think he's he's sort of in his
recovery process from that but I would
like to know I mean I don't know kind of
what Dan and David had planned you know
changed things all the time but I'd like
to think that they will you know bring
bring him back in some some form for
perhaps season four at some point but we
will see we'll see we look forward to
great character he's fantastic here
tonight I've been very much looking
forward to seeing where where they will
take his his role for the next few
seasons but fingers crossed that it'll
be where everyone wants it to go I think
it'd be totally over his terrible wound
that he got a black daughter as well by
then and their awful pain it was
inflicted I know he's heartbroken and
he's probably shoulder broken as well
from that wound so I think there's a lot
of pimp there's a lot for him to kind of
deal with but that's that's where maybe
religion will pop into play a quick
player play its role for him a little
bit but that's I'm looking forward to do
you think he's got what it takes to
survive in Game of Thrones because we've
seen a mania character fall by the way
so I get the chop and other many worse
things everywhere I think I think he
does actually I think the the funny
thing about Lance thought is that he's
easy
he's he's just in the peripheral of a
sort of stage of Game of Thrones enough
to not actually warrant death which is
and it's a really odd way of describing
it but with George not with George
Martin not die is something of a
compliment I suppose so I think he does
have what it takes to survive longer
than most characters really but I mean
come come the seasons that will be
changed by Dan and David and be written
by George I simply have no idea that's
the sort of beauty of the show and off
the books really now if you did have to
get the chart up in the show how would
you like to go out that's such a good
question because I have so many romantic
ideas in my head about what he could be
doing I would like him to I'd like him
ideally to to sort of to some very
simple way of putting it but to die for
the sake of the new character the heat
that you turn that he turns into
basically and which I believe is
completely kind of contrary to the one
he starts off as he goes from squad
then he goes tonight this sort of
pompous prick really broke pubs a little
break but then he will go to something
else and I would like to think that he
will die for that because that's what
really hit me when I read the books so
in whatever man you think I was getting
his head chopped off I don't know but
why not why not have you had a map like
like Ned what have been your favorite
moments of filming so far and that
you've seen on the show you know I think
I think it's it varies usually I loved
doing my scenes with with with Peter in
when I had to sort of to sort of be be
grumbling I really enjoyed that scene as
just before words wise it was very very
fun but there's obviously in terms of
your adrenaline rush the Blackwater
Blackwater Bay just can't be avoided and
I think when we were filming that you
know you eat the lot alongside having to
have all these extras running around
having to do your choreography
choreographed fights it was pouring with
rain and that the ambience was just so
strong and even on camera it it was
stronger in real life than it was in
cameras so I should have felt that that
was probably my favorite moment of the
whole shoot really in terms of setting
in those circumstances and also and of
Helium arts learning the choreography
for the fight how did he find that well
the funny thing is is that that my my
weakness was was this just keep my
footing because it was raining the whole
time and the mud when have you got
people running around doing you know
fighting everything it's like it's like
it's a drunken rugby match times Ted and
so you should have come out going right
you've got a look at you really know
what you do but then you sort of slip
and actually for this for this scene as
well when I was with you and I am I was
trying to keep up with mark but I kept
slipping so keep keeping my feet is my
problem
of course he was a film with Lina in
Headey and Peter Dinklage you mentioned
- what all these guys like as co-stars
the phenomenal I mean I mean whenever I
think of filming with Lina I always
think about one of the first times that
we met which is that what was walking
onto set for my essentially my nude
scene and I was in my dressing gown and
I met her as I was walking in my
dressing gown and I niche is literally I
ended up next time like that's when
how are you literally getting ready to
take off my clothes so that was a fun
fun meeting but she's a charming girl
she really is great to work with and
Peter I mean what can I say I mean all
the above and more he was just he's fine
he's charming he's obviously great to
work with the warrants every every bit
of credit that he gets and and I don't
know if I'll be working with him again
according to the books but either way it
was an honor wonderful you know he is
and I hope I hope people think that
Larson is too I think a great combo
their scenes they cut together in season
two a very funny as well as kind of
cringe-worthy
they are very cringe-worthy yeah I
mentioned this thing about it woman's
view I did have sort of sort of
servitude versus servitude versus kind
of kind of dominance basically and
that's kind of one of the fun bits of
that scene and the next scene when
you're in there in the carriage with
with him it was all about wildfire now
that was that was all that was all fun
to do definitely definitely
now tell me about a typical day on set
what did it involve on Game of Thrones
if there's such a thing of a typical day
it's like a typical day on life it was I
mean it would generally whenever you
whenever you kind of go into doing one
of those scenes you always you can't
help but have high expectations but
they're always beaten whether it's doing
a kind of very intimate one-on-one scene
or whether it's doing a scene of just
absolute the huge magnitude and a
typical day would usually involve would
usually involve just think having a
really good laugh with with with cast
and crew before you walk on and
everyone's face just sort of goes this
is stunning so I think shock was always
shock and amazement was always what
would ensue in every scene and in a word
yeah it was no it was it was it was
actually to be honest he wants you once
you get kit off it's fine I mean you
know yeah you kind of sort of get used
to it but no I mean I I kind of having
read the books obviously that gives you
a lot back for me gave me a lot more
incentive some people prefer not to you
some people do but I I did and that kind
of gave me a lot of understanding of
trying to get that in the intimacy right
so I was once it was done I was just
sort of really
happy that it got some got incorporated
into it you in what about you done it
and then it had been pulled with you
well I wouldn't want to have done it and
then and then no one understands the
context is he naked I don't get it but
no yeah that was some that was fun to do
that was would like a bit more idea
people it's like behind the scenes on a
TV show how many people you got milling
around or you know involved in the
production onset when you're doing
something is kind of intimate and you
know
it can range so heaven I mean it when we
were doing again black Walt always comes
up there were about two hundred extras
when we were trying to do the the siege
scene over the five day night shoots and
it was it was absolutely unbelievable
because you're obviously you're thinking
about what you have to do within your
character and your fighting see what you
know appreciate is that all these other
extras have choreographed fights as well
and I didn't realize that until I
actually got to look over the wall at
them and all of them weren't just sort
of meeting in the middle running each
other and sort of going you go first you
know they actually had an idea of what
they were doing peppermint rain so the
level of commitment was some was
incredible and these stunt guys were
just working the whole time making sure
everyone was okay
so I think just amazement again unlike
this scene with leaner as well as we
talked about earlier when you've got
that bedroom scene I mean how many
people have you got I mean ideally I
suppose you'd want to see if you for the
forcible would do yeah I mean they said
you know we've got a closed set but the
thing is I who you are obviously but you
sort of go into a mind fro really and
this could happen anyway so I think they
know what I don't really care that much
you know it fits them if they need to be
there then I have absolutely no problem
with it so but yes they always say it's
a closed set as it goes now I know we
live like one so I know you love playing
land cell but if you weren't land so
which other character would you like to
be on the show
be anyone I've said this what I've said
this once but I always rethink my
answers I'd like to be um and there's
three that I've broken that ki-moon
father I'm fond of brand I'm fond of
this Ares I thought he was absolutely
great and but I'm also fond of God help
me know Alfie Allen who yeah Theon I
like Theon story because I thought it
was just a really a really kind of
interesting idea of kind of trying to
fit into a family that you're akin to in
blood but not in sort of spirit because
you haven't really been in their
presence for any of your adolescence so
I loved that story that I had a very
interesting theme to me but I think it
would be a competition between brand and
and feel good choices
good storylines are they yeah they are
very good storylines I mean I kind of
it's obviously both and have as is the
case with most most people in the story
about very tragic in a lot of senses but
they they're wonderful george RR Morse
is actually bought a cinema recently and
sent off a little cinema yeah
so do you would you like to see Game of
Thrones the movie yeah that's just as a
relation question I know because I don't
think you're going to get I don't think
you're going to get as much attention to
detail which is what a lot of Game of
Thrones is about if you're in a movie
there's just simply not enough enough
time and I'm speaking for myself when I
go into movies I don't like movies being
too long if I if I see a three and a
half hour movie I come out more sort of
fed up but that's how much I spent in
that I'd liked it to be sort of fairly
concise and so you don't want to lose
that with with roads you want to keep it
- as long winded as possible so you can
enjoy all those moments so I think keep
it keep it to TV keep it to a series I
like I'm liking your thinking definitely
because we look the care and attention
the effort and everything that goes into
the show and it's so beautifully made
exactly exactly I think you would lose
and that attention to detail as much as
Dan and David are fantastic I think they
also have always had always said that
it's it's made for TV
and we love it there exactly we do I'm
glad now what's it meant for you to be
part of Game of Thrones well I think I
think one thing I've always agree with
with the rest of the cast is that you
you are part of an anonymous family I
have probably never met 50% of the
people who are here today doing the
Wales comic-con as well but I and but
when you meet them but you should have
your complete you're very familiar with
them because you would have seen one
another in in varying scenes so I feel
very much done at kind of that I have a
lot more people to meet that I'm already
very close to without you can't be known
them so that's one thing on a personal
level on a professional level you really
do feel I think a nice idea that you're
kind of at the top of a sort of TV game
if you like and you use a lot of there's
a lot of commitment that comes with that
and I've always felt kind of very I've
sort of taken taken it very very
seriously as as a role as a production
and as a kind of entity and also because
they know that a lot of people like to
enjoy it so I think a sense of honour
excitement and and fear actually fear
but fears useful feels useful you're
motivated and if you'll answer a fear
usually entails and quite a few places
and what would you like to say to the
fans of the show who are watching this
video I'd like to say to you that I mean
I don't think you will be going away
because I'm pretty sure you've been hope
you've been enjoying the last three
seasons but as always I mean stay tuned
and you're going to love whatever is
coming up so so well tweet us that's the
best way of keeping in contact and thank
you thank you very much
you